solltest du lieber so tragen oder
andersrum so ist glaube ich besser oder
schreibt man die kommentare was geht ab
und kaufen bei einem neuen video auf
einem kanal und so ja ihr könnt das doch
bestimmt mädchen und jungen verhalten
sich ja im realen leben in jeder
situation unterschiedlich und ich hab
mir aber so ein paar beispiele
rausgesucht deswegen geht es heute um
dinge wie die jungs bzw mädchen machen
ich will gar nicht lange lagern viel
spaß mit dem video und bitte nehmt das
jetzt nicht allzu persönlich falls euch
da irgendwas nicht passt ansonsten wenn
ihr teils weiten ball klebt ein normalen
daumen nach oben so beim video und jetzt
viel spaß mit rein und dann würde ich
mal sagen wir fangen ganz stumpf an mit
dem thema essen
okay es gibt natürlich auch eine ganz
gewisse anzahl von mädchen die es dann
doch ungefähr so tun aber das ist dann
doch eher ein bisschen eklig oder so das
nächste thema das ich mir ausgesucht
habe im lautet telefonieren aber ich
glaube das könnte man auch somit
schätzen vergleichen
ich weiß nicht also ist ja eigentlich
weit ist das gleiche bei jungen und
mädchen viel spaß
ja ja doch heute muss ich ja ja ja ich
komme ja bei mir ist auch alles klar du
sag mal hast du heute vielleicht ein
bisschen zeit mit mir shoppen zu gehen
3 uhr wird sich doch prima an ja ich
komme dann bei dir rum
ja hab ich dich wichtig auch und dann
haben wir als vorletzten punkten auf das
thema aufstehen ich bin mir sich ganz
genau sicher wie mädchen aufstehen aber
ich könnte mir so ungefähr denken
o
wie sich überhaupt aus schrecklich
ja dann zum schluss noch facebook
profilbild aktualisieren gibt es ja
natürlich auch unterschiede und das ist
dann auch der letzte punkt leute also
viel spaß
ich glaub neues facebook profilbild ist
mal wieder drin ja gut nehmen wir
einfach dass auch mein scheiße aussieht
was meine letzte profil aktualisierung
liegt schon zwei tage zurück das kann
doch nicht sein aber da müssen wir
schnell wieder neue fotos raus direkt
mal hier dieter kempf starten
der filter gefällt mir mache erstmal 20
und dann werden die jetzt noch
bearbeitet das gibt's doch nicht dass
ich doch total schrecklich darauf aus
egal dann machen wir nochmal 30 neue so
leute das war's denn jetzt schon wieder
mit diesem video ich hoffe natürlich es
hat euch jemanden fallen und ich hab ja
eben schon gesagt falls sie im bock auf
teil 2 habt dann gebt einfach mal nach
oben
ansonsten abonniere nicht vergessen wenn
ihr nichts mehr verpassen wollte ich
habe mich letzte woche erst für 5000
abonnenten mit einem jetzt sind wir
schon über 6000 auf jeden fall krasses
dankeschön dafür und check doch einfach
mal die beschreibung auch für instagram
facebook und co ansonsten links weiter
mit einem netz video das waren dinge die
medien an jugendliche verstehen und hier
unten rechts mit der sieben sekunden
channels mit meiner freundin wir sehen
uns nächstes wochenende wieder haut rein
job und schönes wochenende schönen
sonntag